ماهذا الازدحام في كل مكان،
إنه ازدحام أمام الصيدليات في أوروبا
، ما الذي يجري؟ هل هناك وباء جديد؟
.. ظهور لأقوى قنبلة عرفها التاريخ
وهي أقوى سلاح رآها البشر
أو سيرونها فكيف سيتجنب الغرب
سلاحا روسيا كهذا؟..
الإجابة لدى ترامب المعتوه
فلديه لكل مشكلة حل فما هو الحل
هذه المرة يا ترى يا دونالد؟....
الهجمات الروسية تبدأ على أمريكا
باختراق للأنظمة الحكومية وأنظمة الشركات
بينما بايدن يحذر من هجمات سيبرانية
على الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية تعدها روسيا..
اليابان تظهر على جدول أعمال موسكو
فهل تكون هي الهدف القادم؟
ومجنون كوريا قد يحقق أمنيته
ويمحو اليابان من الخارطة،،..
الاتحاد الأوروبي يشكل قوة موحدة
خوفا من بوتين، وعقوبات تركية
على موسكو وبوتين يتوعد بالرد
(قنبلة القيصر الروسية)
بعد تخوف غربي من استخدام موسكو
للقنابل الفراغية ذات التأثير القوي،
ها هو الغرب والعالم يعيشون رعبا
لم يسبق له مثيل، فالحديث اليوم عن
قنبلة القيصر الروسية أو إيفان الكبير
كما يطلق عليها الروس،
وهي أكبر قنبلة هيدروجينية على مر التاريخ،
تعادل قوتها التدميرية ثلاثة أضعاف
قوة تدمير قنبلة هيروشيما
أو تفجير ٥٠ مليون طن من مادة TNT،
طولها ٨ أمتار وارتفاعها مترين،
بوزن ٢٧طن..ووصفت بأنها
أقوى سلاح صنعه البشر...
في عام ١٩٦١ تم إطلاق هذه القنبلة
على جزيرة في المحيط المتجمد الشمالي،
نتائج هذه التجربة المخيفة
صعقت العالم كله حيث وصل الارتفاع الأقصى
للسحابة الناتجة عن الانفجار 64 كلم،
وبلغ عرضها 40 كلم. وتم رؤية وهج الانفجار
من منطقة تبعد ١٠٠٠كم عن تلك الجزيرة
(في مشهد مخيف ومرعب)...
(عقار خاطئ)
سارع الناس إلى شراء عقار يوديد البوتاسيوم،،
ظنا منهم أنها قادرة على الحماية
من الإشعاعات النووية، ونتيجة لزيادة الطلب عليها،
ارتفعت أسعارها بشكل جنوني،
بلغ الاستهلاك للعقار ذروته في الدول الأوروبية
وأمريكا، مع نفاد العقار وانعدامه،
لكن منظمة الصحة العالمية أصدرت تقريرا:
وقالت أن العقار ليس ترياقا مضادا للاشعاعات النووية
ولا يستطيع وقف تسربها في الجسم،
ويقتصر دوره فقط على حماية الغدة الدرقية..
وحذرت من تناوله لغرض الوقاية فقط
( قلق غربي)
قال الرئيس الأمريكي جو بايدن إن روسيا
ربما تخطط لشنّ هجوم إلكتروني
على الولايات المتحدة، مؤكدا وجود دلائل
بأن الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين يفكر
في استخدام الأسلحة البيولوجية والكيماوية.
وأضاف بايدن في كلمة أمام رؤساء تنفيذيين
لشركات أمريكية، أن بوتين “أصبح معزولا
وهو يتحدث عن حجج زائفة مثل أسلحة بيولوجية”.
وقال في رسالة موجهة إلى بوتين
“ستكون هناك عواقب وخيمة في حال
قامت روسيا بهجمات سيبرانية ضدنا”.
(رعب ياباني)
هناك فارق شاسع بين قوة سلاح روسيا
وعظمة جيشها مقارنة بما تمتلكه اليابان،،،،
لذلك فليس هناك فرصة لتخوض اليابان
حربا ضد الدب الروسي...
وهنا علقت روسيا محادثاتها بشأن
جزر الكوريل المتنازع عليها مع طوكيو
منذ نهاية الحرب العالمية الثانية...
موسكو ألغت السماح بسفر المواطنين اليابانيين
إلى الجزر بدون تأشيرة، كما أعلنت
تجميد الأنشطة الاقتصادية المشتركة
بين البلدين في الجزر، جاء ذلك على إثر
فرض اليابان لعقوبات على روسيا
بسبب حرب أوكرانيا.
(ليدخل مجنون كوريا أيضا  على الخط،
فبعد تجارب لصوريخ باتجاه اليابان،
ينتظر المجنون أن تحين له فرصة كهذه.،
فتوتر علاقات حليفه بوتين مع أعدائه اليابانيين
الذين هم حلفاء ألد أعداء المجنون أمريكا،
يجعل موعد شن حرب على اليابان
أقرب من أي وقت مضى،
فأسلحة كيم قد تبيد اليابان تماما)
(معتوه أمريكا)
يحاول الرئيس الأمريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
(المعتوه)، أن يظهر بأنه المنقذ،
وأنه سيحل أي مشكلة في العالم،
وإن أردتم استشارته في قضية ما فما عليكم
إلا زيارته أو طلبه في مؤتمر صحفي،
بيد أن ما أثار الجدل مجددا هذه المرة ،
هو اقتراح ترامب خطة جديدة لردع بوتين
ووقف الحرب على أوكرانيا،
وذلك عبر إرسال غواصات نووية
إلى الساحل الروسي، وتحريكها بشكل متكرر،
ترامب وصف بلاده أيضا بأنها أقوى قوة نووية
في العالم ولديها أقوى الأسلحة في العالم،
(بلادك لا تجرؤ على خطوة كهذه
قد تعود عليها بالدمار والإبادة،
يبدو أنك تهرف بما لا تعرف أيها المعتوه)
(التطورات والأحداث)
الدفاع الروسية تعلن تدمير 97 منشأة
عسكرية أوكرانية خلال الساعات الماضية.
الدفاع الأوكرانية: قواتنا في ماريوبول
أسقطت أمس المقاتلة الـ100 لروسيا
منذ بداية الغزو.
لكن موسكو تنفي ذلك حيث قالت أنها لم تدخل
العمليات العسكرية بهذا العدد من الطائرات
فكيف أسقطت أوكرانيا هذا العدد المبالغ فيه يا ترى؟
ديمتري بيسكوف المتحدث باسم الكرملين:
بوتين لم يحقق بعد أهدافه من العملية العسكرية،
في أوكرانيا لكنها تجري وفق المخطط لها......
وعقيدتنا تملي علينا ألا نستخدم
السلاح النووي إلا في حال تهديد وجودي.
المتحدث باسم الإدارة العسكرية لأوديسا
يعلن قتل قائد لواء مشاة البحرية الروسية
خلال محاولة فاشلة لاقتحام المدينة.
تحركات أمريكية مكثفة لمواجهة الحرب الروسية
وجدول حافل برحلات مكوكية لبايدن
إلى الدول الأوروبية
حرب أوكرانيا تجدد الخلاف الحدودي
بين اليابان وروسيا
هيئة الأركان الأوكرانية:
تحرك مكثف للمعدات الروسية والبيلاروسية
على حدود أوكرانيا مع بيلاروسيا.
تبنى الاتحاد الأوروبي خطة عمل
"دفاعية وأمنية" جديدة تقضي بإنشاء
قوة رد سريع قوامها 5 آلاف مقاتل.
روسيا تعلن أول عملية تبادل أسرى مع أوكرانيا:
الدفاع التركية: سنطبق قرارات الأمم المتحدة
بشأن العقوبات على روسيا رغم علاقاتنا
الحسنة بها.
لكن هل تستطيع تركيا تحمل نتائج هذا القرار؟،
فمواجهة دب روسيا تعني الإضرار بتركيا
اقتصاديا وسياسيا بل وعسكريا،
لتستمر تركيا بتخبطاتها وسط انهيار اقتصادها
في الآونة الأخيرة.
رمضان قديروف: القوات الشيشانية التي تقاتل
في ماريوبول تتقدم بنجاح من حي لآخر،
وأكد أن السيطرة على المدينة باتت قريبة
قال الرئيس الأمريكي بايدن،
إن هناك معلومات استخباراتية تكشف
تخطيط الرئاسة الروسية (الكرملين)
بشكل جدي لشن هجمات محتملة،
وحث الشركات الأمريكية على توخّي الحذر
لتعزيز الأمن السيبراني، ومرونة الخدمات،
والتقنيات الحيوية التي يعتمد عليها الأمريكيون”.
لافروف: الغرب هو من وضع أوكرانيا في موقف
الاختيار بين الاصطفاف مع الغرب أو روسيا
ويتحمل تبعات ذلك.
الرئيس الأوكراني خلال كلمة أمام البرلمان
الياباني: القوات الروسية هي من بدأت الحرب المتوحشة
على بلادنا.
وقال زيلينسكي أيضا :
يجب الضغط بقوة على روسيا وإجبارها
على القبول بالسلام ووقف الحرب
ديمتري بيسكوف المتحدث باسم الكرملين:
يشكر الدول التي تحاول التوسط في المفاوضات
الروسية الأوكرانية ويقول أن الأهم من بحث مكان
المفاوضات هو ممارسة نفوذ على أوكرانيا
وجعلها أكثر تعاونا..
المتحدث باسم الدفاع الأمريكية جون كيربي:
تجري هناك مناقشات مستمرة مع دول كثيرة
حول تزويد أوكرانيا بقدرات دفاعية،
بما فيها أنظمة مضادة للجو بعيدة المدى،
سيكون استخدامها مريحا".
حرب سيبرانية تندلع وأسلحة ننووية
على أهبة الاستعداد ومعارك شراء للعلاج
في الصيدليات، هكذا هو حال الغرب بعد الحرب
الروسية الأوكرانية، فمن سيتنازل أولا
لإيقاف هذه الحرب يا ترى؟